a bitterly cold spate of global warming
has struck the East Coast freezing
harbors and blanketing whole cities
under its swell tree frost according to
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration this bomb cyclone occurs
when a cold air mass collides with a
warm air mass and despite the intense
name the phenomenon is actually quite
common particularly in the northern
Atlantic regions but forget all that
science mumbo-jumbo the mainstream media
have wasted no time in identifying the
clear culprit behind the frigid cold
front man caused global warming now
because weather is weather not climate
except when it's convenient for
Democrats in which case the weather
becomes the climate we will analyze this
bitterly cold global warming with former
MIT atmospheric physicist and
catastrophic climate change skeptic
Richard linson then this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
we have a lot to talk about today we've
got to analyze the bomb cyclone I can't
wait to get to Richard Lin's and we're
gonna bring them on right at the top the
end this day in history but first before
we can do any of that we got to keep the
lights on in this place
so we have to thank rain ring is some
pretty amazing technology rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer so you've
probably seen this all your cool friends
who have like cool houses and stuff
might have this it's that video doorbell
so that when you ring the bell they can
just see you on their cell phones from
wherever they are and they can answer
and talk back to you
so today over a million people use the
amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes ring knows that home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end there so now they're
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight cam for most of my viewers
and listeners you'll know what a
floodlight cam is because when you're
trying to break into somebody's house
that's the light that shoots on and
catches you and then you scurry away in
fear well now a good law-abiding
homeowners will be able to see you when
you do that because even if the bad guys
try to steal your doorbell or steal the
floodlight camera that video will be
uploaded straight to the cloud people
will already see it you can catch the
bad guys you can see and speak to
visitors even set off an alarm right
from your phone and that is HD video
that's two-way audio lets you know the
moment anyone steps onto your property
with rings floodlight camera when things
go bump in the night or when you go bump
in the night you will immediately know
what it is whether you're home or away
the ring floodlight camera lets you keep
an eye on your home from anywhere it is
the ultimate in home security
remember in the old days they used to
have the neighborhood watch and you'd
send then people would still rob your
neighborhoods all the time this is the
21st century get with the 21st century
these are amazing price points for
incredible technology it is the ultimate
so there is high visibility flood lights
powerful HD camera put security in your
hands I know they did an experiment in a
bad neighborhood of La they gave out a
bunch of ring technology and they saw
within six months of 55 percent decrease
in Homburg
that is incredible plus it's like
something out of the Jetsons so be sure
to go get it right now today you can
save up to $150 off of a ring security
kit when you go to ring.com slash
knowles Kayano wles
that is ring comm slash knowles what is
it Marshall
slash anoles that's the one okay so I've
got family back on the East Coast in the
bomb cyclone of global warming things
are looking pretty bad here are just a
few photos of it here you can see
Niagara Falls is freezing as the water
molecules prepare themselves to
evaporate into the broiling atmosphere
you can see some shoppers and Dumbo
Brooklyn or E or they're actually
ignoring that do not cross signs as they
race across the street to escape the
Blazing Sun and speaking of Brooklyn
another trendy Brooklyn ID is donning
half of a snorkel in her tropical
paradise a tractor sweeps the bubbling
asphalt off of the main drag in Bellport
New York and look at this a despondent
puppy in Bryant Park begs his owner to
trim his coat just a little bit shorter
if only there weren't so much man cause
global warming three beach Bros cruise
Main Street Medford New York on jet skis
boy oh boy that man cause global warming
really is unbelievable to help us
explain the situation we now bring on
Richard Linson Richard is an atmospheric
physicist specializing in the dynamics
of the middle atmosphere atmospheric
tides and ozone photochemistry
all things about which I know absolutely
nothing he has published more than 200
scientific papers and books he is the
recipient of many awards including the
American Meteorological Society 's
meisinger and Charney awards probably
mispronouncing that the american
geophysical union z' massal wayne metal
and the leo prize from the Wallen
foundation in göteborg sweden he is a
member of countless climate science
advisory boards and until 2013
Richard worked for 30 years as the
Alfred P Sloan professor of meteorology
at MIT has that for an introduction
Richard thank you for being here
pleasure being with you Michael so
Richard in September even the Washington
Post where as you might have read too
reseed eyes in darkness they reported on
a new study in the journal Nature
Geoscience adjusting the settled science
of global warming
Pravda on the Potomac reports quote a
team of ten researchers led by Richard
Miller of the University of Oxford
recalculated the carbon budget for
limiting the Earth's warming to one and
a half degrees Celsius 2.7 degrees
Fahrenheit above temperatures seen in
the late 19th century it had been widely
assumed that this stringent target would
prove unachievable but the new study
would appear to give us much more time
to get our act together if we want to
stay below it what this paper means is
that keeping warming to one and a half
degrees Celsius still remains a
geophysical possibility contrary to
quite widespread belief Miller said in a
news briefing
professor linson why does the so-called
settled science keep changing well
obviously it's not settled whether it's
equally true that there are certain
problems with these hyped up statements
I mean if you think about it a little
bit you know the temperature has already
gone up since the 19th century by about
a degree this has been a period of the
greatest advances in human welfare in
history why do we suddenly feel that the
next 1/2 degree is the end of the world
it makes no sense whether we'll go above
that or not I have no idea but I'm
almost sure that its consequences would
be fairly minimal and you know you make
a great point that whenever we're
talking about this climate debate will
the temperature go up another degree or
half a degree or one and a half degrees
we're ignoring the the greatest advances
in human prosperity in the history of
the world were ignoring the Industrial
Revolution
you know many distinguished scientists
including yourself reject the so-called
climate consensus pushed by politicians
we saw 16 scientists sign that Wall
Street Journal article in 2012 arguing
the decarbonizing the world
economy with severely hamper economic
growth quality of life especially in the
third world that it's not justified by
the scientific evidence and yet people
with little to no scientific training
reject all of you highly credentialed
scientists as climate deniers has the
world turned upside down on what should
be a scientific issue I suppose you
could say that I mean you know the 97%
is a curious thing I mean it's the
number that they've decided on that will
convince people as you say you don't
know anything about subject I wouldn't
say anyone I mean what I find for
example is if I you know talk to my
plumber or electrician or anyone like
that they don't take this seriously I'm
pretty sure people in what we refer to
as flyover country don't take it
seriously I think the only people who
take it seriously are people who went to
college who don't understand science are
worried about it and are reassured if
somebody tells them however falsely that
97% agree and they're comforted and they
feel oh that's fine they never check
what the 97% refers to I mean one of the
studies was asking people you know as
the climate warmed since the last 150
years and his man played any role in it
whatever you know everyone who works and
it would agree you know both those
statements so probably are correct they
have no catastrophic implication but
they leave it to people to assume that
means the end of the world is nigh
others have done all sorts of other
fudges but the truth of the matter is
that probably if you asked weather
forecasters media weather forecasters
it's always been over half don't think
there's anything remarkable happening
that number as you say seems
perfectly tuned to be used by
politicians and demagogues in the media
to convince people that something
terrible is happening and your statement
on people who are doing jobs who maybe
they don't have a bachelor's degree or
they didn't go to somebody late school
in the United States they're not
terribly worried they're not screaming
for their family's welfare and saying oh
no who-who cares about how much money
we're making and how our investments are
doing and whether we can put the kids to
college
global warming is going to kill us all
it seems evidence of an age-old truth
that a little learning is a dangerous
thing because if you asked any of my
classmates at college or a many any
college student today in the United
States they would call you crazy yeah I
think that's true but you know think
about what education is about I mean you
know unfortunately have come to the
conclusion that for the most part what a
good student it refers to as a student
who has learned to rationalize anything
in order to please the professor that's
a maybe a useful skill in some instances
but it will certainly lead you astray
when you're confronted by something
fairly absurd and your special ability
is you can rationalize it that's a great
point Allan bloom wrote about the tenor
of college students in the closer of
American mind
he said the nice the the best thing you
could say about them is that they're
nice and that is a damning indictment
and speaking of the university speaking
of academic life scientific careers from
what I have read have been ruined for
contradicting global warming orthodoxy I
read about - Maurice Albee American
atmospheric physicist who is a so-called
climate dissenter seems that he was
fired by Macquarie University for his
views the university even canceled a
non-refundable return ticket from his
European speaking engagement he all
because he has dissented is there is it
fair to say that there are professional
incentives
toed the line on global warming in the
Academy of course of course there are I
mean Murray's case is really sad he's a
very good atmospheric scientist and they
not only did everything you said but you
know that they prohibited him access to
his papers and everything is absolutely
Stalinist his entire career at GMAT of
photographs maybe yeah I mean it is that
sort of thing truly bizarre I would say
if you're a young scientist and don't
have tenure this will kill you if you
dissent if you are still active and
senior you'll still be cut off from
funding so yeah sure it's more than an
incentive and for university
administration's the the fact that this
has become a matter of student activism
that students somehow feel that they are
displaying their virtue by condemning
co2 which happens to be vital for life I
mean yeah it's a bit crazy but nothing
frightens an administrator more than an
activist student an excellent point and
did you yourself feel protected a bit
you were well ensconced well established
nationally and at MIT I know I spoke to
Harvey Mansfield the tenured philosopher
at Harvard who said that once he got
tenure he felt he could raise a little
hell did you think you were protected in
a way that younger or less established
professors were not of course of course
you know it's supposed to be the purpose
of tenure to give you the freedom to
pursue the truth in whatever way you can
on the other hand that is less important
today than it used to be because your
position at the university depends very
critically on your ability
raise funds and that in turn means
everyone including senior people have an
immense incentive to toe the line and
you know it's always been known that
this is a danger especially in science
and especially in a science like
atmospheric physics or climate where the
government has a virtual monopoly on
support and in the government
oh yeah that's the point if they have a
position then that's going to be a real
limitation on freedom of inquiry and in
terms of this they have this monopoly
and they have an agenda they fund all of
it and then there is a little old us
there's the general public so I want to
get into the the science itself what is
often presented as facts to the general
public or actually themselves based on a
lot of assumptions as to how to
aggregate and adjust raw measurements
how do we calculate measurements such as
say the global mean temperature which we
all hear about what do those
measurements tell us about the so-called
consensus and the certainty of the
scientific community well it's not as
easy to question this and it takes a
career to figure this out if one even a
Canyon I mean part of the problem is the
metric of global mean temperature
obviously there's no such meaningful
thing there to say you can't average
Mount Everest with the Dead Sea and you
know get anything meaningful right you
don't lift your finger into the air and
say oh yes I found the global mean
temperature it's 42 degrees now you
obviously can't do that and they try and
do something that's a little bit more
sensible you know in each station they
take the average over 30 years and look
at the deviation from that average then
average those deviations over the globe
usually with the area averaging at least
but you know it's never perfectly clear
the most
amazing thing about that number by the
way is that it's very close to zero
mm-hmm
I mean you know one degree 1/2 degree in
a century or one degree in a century
that's very tiny you know every day here
in New England you are talking about the
cold today it's actually above freezing
oh yeah looking like you went up about
15 degrees centigrade
you can't perceive one degree it's as
I've pointed out to people variation in
such things is essential I mean for
instance if you tracked your body
temperature compulsively you would
discover it's not constant if you look
at a skyscraper it's always swaying
natural systems have to vary a little
bit in order to maintain stability so to
treat you know as people did in speaking
of the hottest year on record
it's a hundredth of a degree warmer than
it was another year
this is insane and you're counting on
the fact that people have no idea of
what these quantities mean so you know
something I'm sorry go ahead
no so you have something that hasn't
changed much but you have people arguing
did it go up a hundredth degree did it
go down I'm not sure this metric means
anything and frequently I think the
consensus view the popular consensus
view is that the only way that we have
stability in complex systems is total
stasis perfect stasis but of course
there's no reason to assume that
obviously these systems have variability
as you say just to maintain their own
stability and that in also on the
uncertainty of these oh I'm sorry go
ahead if you had a rigid skyscraper what
would happen to it it collapse right so
the stasis you're talking about
would be extremely dangerous mm-hmm
that's your fluctuates because it has a
restoring force and in in terms of the
uncertainty of some of these
measurements and in calculating some of
the variation and some of the cost
William Nordhaus maybe the the foremost
climate change economist he has observed
the massive uncertainty in calculating
the cost of global warming and policies
to combat global warming so depending on
the model you pick and depending on my
own lack of talent at reading these
papers but it appears that the social
cost of carbon which is the amount that
you would tax carbon to efficiently
capture all of its externalities is
anywhere from around say 50 cents per
ton of carbon dioxide to around $50 to
around $48 per ton of carbon dioxide
they're way off that range is way off
sure it could be the wrong sign
I mean carbon dioxide increases
agricultural productivity right modest
warming is a net benefit you know within
a plausible range this might be a
benefit the really crazy thing about it
is we're talking about something that I
think in all likelihood is beneficial as
something that we're supposed to be
horribly afraid of well that well that's
an excellent point because as I was
looking at those numbers I was just
thinking of how the government would try
to tax it to keep some sort of stasis or
whatever but and and that's a often what
is talked about is the cost of global
warming right as you point out it could
be a benefit to the economy and it could
be a benefit to the environment it could
be a benefit to humanity mm-hmm I mean
after all I mean you know fossil fuels
have provided the means for people to
improve their life we spend their life
expectancy and so on so you know even if
there were drawbacks for much of the
world it would be immense boon you
you see this in Germany at the moment in
the UK at the moment there have all
these tax schemes and schemes to use
renewables which increase the cost of
electricity suddenly have people who are
poverty-stricken because they can't
afford energy right that's right and my
colleague Andrew Clavin
often talks about how the the
environmental left they love Avatar they
love the film avatar they say why can't
we live like that where with lights
coming out of trees and things and he
says oh we can and if that's been given
to us by oil and by fossil fuels we do
live in that world that world is a
product of our own ingenuity and using
our resources wisely and given that
there is always uncertainty in modeling
these long-term outcomes I mean is it a
benefit as it is there some cost in
these complex real world systems how
would you say our lawmakers should think
about making so-called science-based
policy well let me give you an example
of run into you know lawmakers are
increasingly asking for regional
forecast you know how are things going
to be in Colorado or in California or in
Southern California or Massachusetts now
they're using models and they're running
them and if they look carefully they
find that the models are giving them any
answer they want they're all over the
place
the fundamental question they should ask
is you know for instance in any given
season there's a regional distribution
of the seasonal climate do these models
if you pick this correctly the answer is
no can they handle the seasonal cycle in
general the answer for most models in
fact all of them as far as I can tell is
they do that very poorly so if they
don't even meet elementary tests you
have to accept you don't know and then
you run into the insanity of the
precautionary principle says you don't
have to know you just have
to worry and that's enough to legislate
and that's it that's something that's
what are more scary than absolutely
right
and with organizations like the IPCC
with which you have been involved and
organizations that seem to be largely
influenced by politics and largely are
trying to influence governments to take
preventative measures and damage their
own economies or the global economy is
there any way to get the politics out of
it and to get the demagoguery out of it
or are those groups and organizations
formed by say the United Nations are
they too hopelessly for gone to be
brought back to any sort of academic
freedom and rigor you know I don't know
the answer to that and I'll explain why
I don't know the answer to that the part
of the IPCC that I was associated with
or at least the first three run through
subject I was working group one dealing
with the science and to be sure it was
biased but in general it wasn't that bad
it you know had this sort of summary
statement and you should think about
that a little bit you know they came out
with a statement there they're pretty
darn sure that most of the warming over
the last 50 years was due to man and you
had politicians like Lieberman and
McCain and so on saying see we've got
the smoking gun we have to do something
the world is coming to an end that
statement had no such meaning in fact it
was most consistent with the statement
this where there's no problem the
politicians have taken the view that if
man has any impact at all that's a
disaster that's a disaster and it has to
be corrected and yes gets to an another
real politicized aspect of this science
which is that term consensus keeps being
thrown around we talked earlier about
the 90
seven percent number Lord only knows
where they got that number from and
which surveys went went into arriving at
that number same place they got polar
bears from I'm sure there's focus groups
those poor polar bears I we must have
really done something right because I
hear their populations have increased
actually over the last century lucky
them you know they'll attack human
beings without provocation
but they look cute very cuddly you know
at least the plush animals of them are
very cuddly but this word consensus two
days the word consensus is bandied about
it reminds me of that scene in The
Princess Bride where I say you keep
using that word I don't think you I
don't think that word means what you
think it means why the focus on
consensus the last time that I checked a
scientific advancements are not made by
democratic or popular vote
why have they glommed on to that and
does the so-called scientific consensus
have much bearing in the in the pursuit
of science itself no I mean you know it
tends to influence things like funding
and so on because peer review is
something that is very much designed to
maintain consensus that is to say you
have to convince your peers that you
agree with them or yeah so in that sense
it's it's important but no in terms of
scientific progress it's always been
pretty much something that goes outside
the consensus that turns out to be
important now I think what this is
appealing to is that people ever heard
instinct and if you tell them everyone
agrees with something that will convince
them that's right and my my final
question I suppose I'm asking for a
prediction and I know that all of the
climate predictions have been so far off
but I say I'm a big fan of yours
not because of any of your immense body
of scientific work about
which I know absolutely nothing and I
understand very little but I'm a big fan
that you are heterodox in the Academy at
the University you have contravened
academic and political orthodoxies of
recent years do you see that situation
improving on the American campus in in
the near future or things gonna just
keep getting worse and worse and it's
always darkest before it gets even
darker I like to think it's always
darkest before the dawn one hopes that's
the other that's the other view I
suppose but yeah I I don't know I mean I
what I find with students is they
realize that they've been pushed into a
corner I find that the activists among
the students are not a majority but they
certainly have the power to intimidate
their peers largely through the
accommodations of the administrators at
universities university administrators
have become my kind of disaster area
mm-hmm and they keep increasing they
keep hiring more and more assistant dean
on this Oh it's outrageous I mean at MIT
I don't think the faculty or student
numbers have changed all that much since
1960 but administrators are all over and
of course they need the grant overheads
to support themselves you know it's it's
not a good situation and I think
students to some extent realize that so
there's some hope maybe they'll take
inspiration from you know an uprising in
Iran and realize that they have mullahs
that they have to overthrow as well they
do and you you identified the problem I
noticed that people ask all the time
because all of the craziness on campuses
these days I'm sorry to report comes
from dear old Yale and I they say well
when you were there was it as crazy and
the students on this so the problem
really wasn't the students and I never
found it to be
faculty I had wonderfully Marxist
faculty who were quite accommodating and
serious and dealt with me very well
it's these administrators who have let
the the whole place run amok and have
really hollowed it out from within so I
suppose we can hope that they they get
what's theirs and we riot in the streets
and throw at our academic mullahs that's
a wonderful hopeful note to end on
Richard Linz and thank you so much for
being here you've cleared this up a lot
for us we really appreciate it
and we'll have to have you back on
sometime have a good year as well okay
we have got to get to this day in
history but first before we do that I'm
sorry folks if you're on Facebook or
YouTube we appreciate having you but you
got to go to the Daily wired.com right
now if you already subscribe thank you
you keep the lights on
you keep qoph fa in my cup if not go to
daily wire.com right now you will get me
you'll get the end reclaim ensure you
get the Ben Shapiro show blah blah blah
but you will get the leftist here's
tumblr now look there there is a cyclone
bomb in the East Coast there are
delusions of floods on the west coast
there is very bitterly cold global
warming all of this extreme weather is
going to end in a Noahide a NOAA like
flood of salty delicious leftist years
do not be caught unawares you do not
know the day or the hour that it will
come get your leftist ears tumblr go to
daily wire calm right now we'll be right
back
[Music]
speaking of the climate variations on a
theme it's time for this day in history
this day in history on this day in
history nearly an inch of snow fell
every hour for 16 consecutive hours
starving cattle and ruining ranchers in
the American West know that extreme
weather didn't happen last year or the
year before that or the year before that
nope the worst day of the worst winter
in the West took place 131 years ago
long before Democrat hacks ever blamed
weather events on unfalsifiable
apocalyptic theories plains ranchers in
Montana Wyoming and the Dakotas knew
nothing of the ozone layer or the
greenhouse effect or political
demagogues seizing upon any natural
phenomenon to tighten their grip on
power if they had surely they would have
blamed the unseasonable hot and dry
summer of 1886 on I don't know
industrialization or deforestation or
whatever that unseasonable dry autumn
left the range almost completely barren
of grass with vulnerable cattle herds
wandering around hungry
worse yet the snows came early that year
beginning in November and blanketing the
plains by January with a record snowfall
the cold front even reached the Pacific
Ocean dropping an all-time record 3.7
inches of snowfall in downtown San
Francisco on February 5th although a
warm wind briefly melted top layers of
January and that actually turned out
worse because the returning cold created
a thick layer of ice over the entire
ground making it virtually impossible
for cattle to dig through to the
remaining grass beneath futile attempts
on the part of man to predict the
weather years out compounded the problem
by the mid 1880s after several
consecutive warm winters the warmest
winters on record they probably thought
proto climatologists in the West started
over stocking the ranges with cattle
while they simultaneously stopped
storing away winter feed for a snowy day
modern climatologists can simply change
their models hide the decline when their
predictions don't come to fruition while
political hacks explain away their
failures
and at the same time double down on
their own hysterical claims the plains
ranchers of 1886 and 1887 weren't so
lucky they had to sit by and watch as
their cattle slowly died historian
Joseph Kinsey Howard recalled starving
cattle staggered through village streets
and collapsed and died in dooryards five
thousand of the animals stormed the
outskirts of Great Falls devouring what
little the townspeople had only just
planted and crying from hunger as they
died the great die up as it came to be
called because the American West is very
whimsical killed off millions of cattle
including half of Montana's entire herd
their carcasses lined the countryside
hundreds of ranchers fell into sudden
bankruptcy some modern climate
prognosticators are willing to send
whole national economies into bankruptcy
even as their predictions continually
prove just as inaccurate as Western
speculators in the 1880s but the
alarmists keep up their hysterical
drumbeat the science has settled they
say the solutions are obvious it's just
common sense we have seen the future and
it works right also on this day in
history in 1776 Thomas Paine published
his pamphlet common sense in it he
writes quote a long habit of not
thinking a thing wrong gives it a
superficial appearance of being right
and raises at first a formidable outcry
in defense of custom time makes more
converts than reason pain may have been
more right than he knew in decadent
times common sense is anything but
sensible as the predictions of
self-appointed elites prove wrong time
and time again don't be fooled by
superficial appearances and do not
forfeit your own capacity to reason
that's our show I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show get your
mailbag questions in for Thursday tune
in tomorrow and we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017